500 euro die vip-gäste reebok habe ich
mir lieber erstellt sie kostet halt
wirklich 500 euro von den euro mystery
box machen sie freunden eine freude mit
überraschungen klickpedale auf die
werbung auf jeden fall werden wir
mystery box heute zusammen auf packen
[Musik]
na ja ich habe schon einige ideen im
kopf videos aufnehmen kann also laden
jedoch ist noch ein gott ich habe noch
nie ein video hochgeladen wird mit einer
500 euro mystery box und das erste was
ich sehe werde ich ach du heilige
scheiße 40.000 toilettenpapierrollen
also lieber einsteller dieser ebay
mystery boxen danke auf jeden fall dafür
so oft ich jetzt auch nicht scheiße hier
kommen wir allerdings schon zu den
ersten späteren ersten richtigen produkt
was wir aus und platzieren familienroman
sammelband gefühle kann man lesen geil
ich schön das du deinem vater noch
gesellschaft leistet ich dachte du
würdest schon wieder aufnahmen machen
ich lebe nicht weiter das nächste
produkt das ich in dieser 500 euro im
etat des blogs befindet ist passiert ach
du heilige mutter gottes supermacht ein
paar sekunden später endlich bin ich
aber bereit dafür auf jeden fall auch
für dieses es ist so bescheuert dass ich
danke sagen ich habe 500 euro für die
scheiße gezahlt das nächste produkt
plötzliche vorne mal raus hunde ist eine
systems also allein wenn man sich dieses
szenario hier gerade anschaut abonniert
main kanal kommt darin die zeit da war
ich und wenn das öl wird
lassen bisher haben wir einen familien
liebesromane sind 25 sammle roman in
einem
aber dieses muscle shirt ein smiley
kissen und unzählige rollen
toilettenpapier im das nächste foto
passieren befindet ist balakov weiter
ich hasse kaffee wie die pest
also den kampf auf keinen fall behalten
als nächstes kommen zu diesen hier die
karten mit einem scheißhaufen drauf oh
mein gott das sind socken für jeden tag
am motor geht es mit dem scheiterhaufen
losen am freitag ist dann schon so
partystimmung und an einem sonntag ist
nee das ist dann wiederum der donnerstag
untersagt sind genauso aus für dieses
kissen hier war allerdings direkt weiter
wird im nächsten produkt das in dieser
box wir befinden uns was passieren ein
motiv war möglicherweise gekauft das ist
ein motiv waffeleisen für großenbach
spaß mit tollen tiermotive leisten wir
können dir affen und elefanten machen
nicht mehr lange wenn jemand das grab
machen muss trotzdem okay
das hat sich dann schon gelohnt
[Musik]
nächstes produkt in der del mestre box
ist gibt es hier
okay das auf nein das hast du was ich
schon in meinem aufnahme zimmer habe wo
ich luke schuhe mit mir geschrieben habe
danke danke ich dafür aus der gegend
bitte alle auf die werbung dass ich mit
diesem video mehr als 500 euro rein
kriegen das nächste produkt of the
mystery box ist der klobürste danke auch
für die klobürste kann ich auf jeden
fall gebrauchen mit jule da mal wieder
drauf war
ich greife hier ganz tief nach unten
diesmal und wir haben ein bisschen
handyhalter reformen handy-plattform
schreibtisch zu holen auf jeden
die dann irgendwie hier reinstellen und
dann schild das handy auch klappstuhl ja
auch dann wenn dafür nächstes produkte
ist etwas flauschiges uns war armstulpen
ich habe keine ahnung was arm und ich
habe sie kaputt gemacht keine ahnung was
an schulden sind ich weiß nicht ob man
sich die hier schluss zum glück gar
nicht von youtube video bereit das
nächste produziert ich glaube er hat
dieses ganze toilettenpapier einfach nur
als baumaterial für die ganzen produkte
genutzt also ich hatte noch nie soviel
klopapier irgendeinen schaffen glaube
ich auch in meinem alter sind besser
körper wahrscheinlich silvester körper
feuerwerkskörper an ihrer noch drin
würde ich jetzt auch gern austesten aber
ehrlich gesagt um jede meiner boot
nehmen wir erst einmal das größte paket
was ich bisher in dieser liebe müssen
wie boxee befindet hat und das ist doch
nicht wahr etwa stehe ich auch warum da
so viel toilettenpapier drin war das ist
einfach ein troillet paper blaster der
ganze toilettenpapier sache dran machen
und dann schießt er dass sie in meter
weit und ich mach mir in die hose
[Musik]
trotzdem ich heiße sie herzlich
willkommen auf einem kanal falls sie
noch kein abonnent bist kann ich sie
auch nicht empfehlen das nächste
fotografieren befindet ist ein paar
mingo bay kann ich meiner mutter
schenken bei der wirtschaft feiert war -
irgendwie immer übertrieben und auch in
unserem zuhause haben diese kleine
aufblasbare - überall rum schwimmen cool
story also das ist auf jeden fall vista
flamingo der war noch drin dann habe ich
hier noch ein alter
es ist wie es ist doch mit dem spiegel
dran also dankeschön auch für diesen
spiegel endlich weiß nicht ob man sich
aus der entfernung seien ein spiegelbild
anschauen sollte wenn man es auch so
machen kann aber okay dieses produkt
drin ist ein
ich hasse mein leben ich auch weiter
geht es mit einem neuen buch was hier
drin ist und zwar arzt geschichten ja
sind wieder vier romane drin summarum
juckt aber im endeffekt niemand dann
haben wir hier noch wirklich weitere
unmengen an toilettenpapier drin wenn
ich immer weiter aufgeht ist noch was
schleim im öl fast ich glaub ich bin
nicht der einzige mensch auf der welt
ich dachte dass
ich sage das weil man darf das wäre so
cool aus schleim der so abgeht von der
hand dann aber der hier der kit
ermöglicht ekelhaft habe ich genug von
dem papier das hat wenigstens
vernünftiges toilettenpapier aber das
auch so richtige billiges zum scheiß
musste ich meinen goldenen arsch nicht
alles klar
alles klar dann haben wir hier der ist
ihre boxen noch einige rollen klopapier
drin das war ja wirklich dass er gar
nicht dass hier irgendwelche form von
papier drin sind halt herdentiere eine
vorne haben wir ja das ist schon nicht
wieder so einen scheiß schleim öl fast
keine ahnung was die ganzen müssen wie
die box leute mit schleim haben die
denkt wahrscheinlich jede mögliche die
mit definierten wir die biege
pflegebetrieb in dickeren brocken genau
mit dem ist wie box auch noch 100
prozent fit muss das ist tatsächlich vor
einem jahr abgelaufen also dieser herr
locken muss war da auch noch sind sonst
ja dort 30 vorüber wir aber sonst war's
das auf jeden fall
ich glaube wenn ich den gesamtwert von
dieser mystery park schätzen müsste käme
ich so auf 13 euro auf jeden fall ein
guter deal aus aktuellem anlass
hinsichtlich dem skandal um jack poole
und reis kam und dieser mystery boxcamp
gamble website noch mal ganz kurz hier
ja ich habe 500 euro für diesel loks
ausgeben und der komplette inhalt
scheiße ist nicht mehr als 150 euro wenn
überhaupt wert von daher fällt nicht
auch so was rein
ihr müsst immer bedenken falls ihr euch
sowas kauft die leute die das machen die
werden dann niemals dinge reinpacken die
man für mehr als 500 euro wieder
verkaufen kann und ihr werdet auch
keinen privatjet drin finden also lasst
euch von sowas bitte nicht verarschen
[Musik]
dann würde ich mich sehr sehr dornbach
einen daumen hoch von euch hinter diesem
video hier freunde ein
ich will das nicht noch mal 1000 euro
müsste die box machen bitte tut mir das
nicht
ansonsten würde ich mich freuen wir die
mine
abonieren würdet weil ja ich kann es
eigentlich keinen guten grund dafür
nennen
[Musik]